dire warning from the u.s postal service
that could affect tens of millions of
voters
the post office telling most of the
states that it cannot guarantee delivery
of the expected crush of mail-in ballots
in time for election day counting it
comes as congress and the white house
were to stalemate over a coronavirus
relief bill which would include billions
in funding for the post office
and as the president is seeking to cast
out on mail-in ballots cast in the
upcoming election
ouija jain is traveling with the
president who was spending the weekend
at his new jersey
golf club wija good morning
good morning jeff and good morning to
everybody cbs news has learned that the
postal services inspector general has
launched an investigation
into recent changes at post offices
across the country made by the new
postmaster general
who is a trump appointee democrats say
the changes are part of a concerted
effort to sabotage the election
talk business during a friday night
event at his bedminster golf resort
president trump asked a group of new
york police officers for help
insulting democratic presidential
candidate joe biden
who likes slow joe
who likes sleepy jokes
[Applause]
the city's police benevolent association
the largest union representing nypd
officers endorsed the president's
reelection campaign
back in washington democratic lawmakers
are accusing mr trump of trying to
undermine the election
by withholding emergency funding for the
u.s postal service and a coronavirus
relief deal
at a time when mail and ballots are
expected to increase
tenfold in november due to the pandemic
president trump insists without
providing evidence that mail-in voting
will lead to
election fraud they can be forged
they can be captured they can be taken
but on friday president trump said he
would sign an agreement with mail-in
voting money in exchange for republican
priorities i would i would certainly do
that sure
i would do that in a rare interview
former president barack obama weighed in
on the controversy what we've never seen
before
is a president say i'm going to
try to actively kneecap the postal
service
to encourage voting when i see problems
i work to solve it
the postal service has sent letters to
all 50 states and washington d.c
urging them to change their mail and
voting timelines
and warning several of them that there's
a significant risk that some
ballots will not be returned by mail in
time to be counted
house speaker nancy pelosi continued
pressing for more resources
the removal of equipment within the
postal
offices and the rest is to undermine the
postal service
at a time when the postal service is
needed now more than ever
the national association of letter
carriers which represents 300 000
retired and active postal service
workers has
endorsed the biden harris ticket joe
biden tweeted that vote by mail is safe
and secure
pointing out that just this week the
president himself
requested his mail-in ballot michelle
good what's good for the goose a lot of
people saying that
luigi thank you so much